okay everybody this is my spoiler-free  review of the black phone this is  directed by scott derrickson who i am a  huge fan of who did the first doctor  strange movie what i love about him he  always values story and he is so good at  keeping engaged the whole time that  doesn't change here this movie is one of  those movies that grips you right from  the start and it does not let go i was  in a full theater and half of this  audience was literally sitting upright  in their chair you couldn't hear anyone  talking it it was that engaging it was  actually a really fun movie too uh the  only critique i have of it is that i  think it just misses sticking the  landing it's kind of missing its big  twist or big reveal that doesn't really  happen here but besides that it's one of  the most engaging suspenseful movies i  have seen in a long time this is  definitely a thriller to see and is  worthy one of the best movies of the  year i'm giving this film an 8.8